Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
episode number 500 with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
And on this glorious day, we are going to
simulate the kinematics of yarn and cloth
on our computers.
We will transition into today’s paper in
a moment, but for context, here is a wonderful
work to show you what we were able to do in
2012 and we will see how far we have come
since.
This previous work was about creating these
highly detailed cloth geometries for digital
characters.
Here you see one of its coolest results where
it shows how the simulated forces pull the
entire piece of garment together.
We start out with dreaming up a piece of cloth
geometry, and this simulator gradually transforms
it into a real-world version of that by subjecting
it to real physical forces.
This is a step that we call yarn-level relaxation.
A few years ago, when I worked at Disney Research,
I attended to the talk of the Oscar award
winning researcher Steve Marschner who presented
this paper.
And when I saw these results, shockwaves went
through my body.
It was one of my truly formative “hold on
to your papers” moments that I’ll never
forget.
Now note that to produce these results, one
had to wait for hours and hours to compute
all these interactions.
So, this paper was published in 2012, and
now, nearly 9 years have passed, so I wonder
how far have come some since?
Well, let’s see together!
Today, with this new technique, we can conjure
up similar animations where pieces of garments
tighten.
Beautiful.
Now, let’s look under the hood of the simulator,
and…well, well, well.
Do you see what I see here?
Red dots.
So, why did I get so excited about a couple
red dots?
Let’s find out together!
These red dots solve a fundamental problem
when simulating the movement of these yarns.
The issue is that in the mathematical description
of this problem, there is a stiffness term
that does not behave well when two of these
points slide too close to each other.
Interestingly, our simulated material gets
infinitely stiff in these points.
This is incorrect behavior and it makes the
simulation unstable.
Not good.
So what do we to to alleviate this?
Now, we can use this new technique that detects
these cases and addresses them by introducing
these additional red nodes.
These are used as a stand-in until things
stabilize.
Look, we wait until these two points slide
off of each other.
And now, the distances are large enough so
that the mathematical framework can regain
its validity and compute the stiffness term
correctly, and look, the red dot disappears,
and the simulation can continue without breaking.
So if we go back to another piece of under
the hood footage, we now understand why these
red dots come and go.
They come when two nodes get too close to
each other, and they disappear as they pass
each other, keeping the simulation intact.
And with this method, we can simulate this
beautiful phenomenon when we throw a piece
of garment on the sphere, and all kinds of
stretching and sliding takes place.
Marvelous.
So what else can this do?
Oh boy, it can even simulate multiple cloth
layers, look at the pocket and the stitching
patterns here.
Beautiful.
We can also put a neck tag on this shirt and
start stretching and shearing it into oblivion.
Pay special attention to the difference in
how the shirt and the neck tag reacts to the
same forces.
We can also stack three tablecloths on top
of each other and see how they would behave
if we would not simulate friction.
And now, the same footage with friction.
Much more realistic.
And if we look under the hood, you see that
the algorithm is doing a ton of work with
these red nodes.
Look, the table notes that they had to insert
tens of thousands of these nodes to keep the
simulation intact.
Goodness!
So, how long do we have to wait for a simulation
like this?
The 2012 paper took several hours, what about
this one?
Well, this says we need a few seconds per
timestep, and typically, several timesteps
correspond to one frame, so where does this
put us?
Well, it puts us in the domain of not hours
per every frame of animation here, but to
minutes, and sometimes even seconds per frame.
And not only that, but this simulator is also
more robust as it can deal with these unpleasant
cases where these points get too close to
each other.
So, I think this was a great testament to
the amazing rate of progress in computer graphics
research.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!